Hôm nay, 2 mi tháng tháng 7, các nhà lĩnh đạo Thái Lan và Câm Phu Chi,
bắt đầu cuộc nằm phán đáp mệt tại của la lắm per Malaysia,
nhằm tím kính giải pháp trong rất sâu chẳng biến giới.
Uwho khắp giến ra trong bữa cạnh, căng thẳng leo thang,
khiến nhiều khu phật dân cư, chở thành thị trấn ma,
anh hưởng nghiêm trọng đến ord định khu vực.
Và đoàn thái Lan, gió quyền tủ tướng Thái Lan,
phung tham, về giai giai giai giải, giẫn đầu.
Con đại dễn các buồn chia tham dự các cuộc thảo luận sẽ có thu tướng các buồn chia hôm mặt.
Bối bay trọt chú tịch ASEAN, 2.2.5 Malaysia đã chủ đọt làm chung ra.
Củ Mỹ, đầm tổ chức cuộc đầm phán và có sự phó hợp từ chung quốc.
Hãy bên dự kiến thảo luận về cư chính người bạn ngày lập tức
và thiết lập cân lối thoại lo dài để chánh tài diễn xung đồn.
Giới qua sát nhận định của các này giễ dút ra, mляu thang xung đồn.
Giúp ordn định tình hình giáo dục và đời sống dân cư tại khu vực biên giới.
Đứng tệ mở giác các hội khối phục phá bình lâu dài dựa 2.3.